so hello everybody i am here with father
john strickland
father john is a parish priest in the
seattle area in paulsbo
i hope i said that right in folsvo on
the west coast
he is also on his he has a phd in
history
and so on the side he also writes a blog
he has
made a podcast called the paradise in
utopia and he is now publishing books
he's published
a book called the age of paradise which
i've read and
his second volume which has it come out
yet i think it's coming out soon
yeah it came out in november uh age of
age of division
so the age of division which i'm reading
at at this moment and i think
so much of what he is hinting at the
things he's bringing to the fore
are extremely important at this time to
help us understand history and a more
global vision
of christian history
[Music]
this is jonathan pedro welcome to the
symbolic world
and so father john uh i had just read
the first volume i'm reading the second
volume i'm i'm
very excited to see you do the things
you do
um one of the frustrations that i've had
is as i explored the church fathers and
i explored
the history of the east i realized just
how much was lacking in my own
historical understanding and how so many
movements that happened even in the west
cannot be properly understood unless we
have this more global vision
of of the east and the west together in
this discussion
in this conflict you know a mix of
influences
and so uh maybe you can tell us a little
bit about what prompted you to want to
tell
this this narrative yeah
yeah thanks jonathan well um
so i i was teaching a university uh
full-time
uh before i went off to seminary and
became a parish priest and that's my
main
work now being a parish priest here um
but uh impulsebow but uh but i've always
had this really
really um strong interest in history and
in the the legacy of christianity within
the history of the west
i've always been interested in that
that's what got me interested in history
initially and and so when i decided to
study
history you know at the graduate level
that um
i just i just i got to a point where i
really wanted to understand
as you say globally the history of the
west from a christian
point of view it was always dismaying to
me to see
how little attention was given
to uh to the role of christianity in our
culture and in the formation of our
culture
and when attention was given to it often
it was negative you know the crusades
the inquisition
the witch trials and all those things um
so i really wanted
to learn about that and then i wanted to
tell the story and so
um in the past few years i've had an
opportunity to start writing
these books that are a history of
christmas from its origins
all the way up to the present which is
designed not only as a narrative that's
interesting and just
hopefully enjoyable to read hopefully
interesting just to learn about
history i think that's really important
in itself
but i i really wanted to contribute to
our ongoing um
discussion we have today in america
canada the west
um of where we are culturally and why we
face so many problems culturally
as almost everyone would you know admit
today on the left or the right
and so my book series is itself titled
the rise and fall of what the west once
was
and it's a history of what i call
christendom
a word that i appropriate from its kind
of medieval use i don't like the term
medieval we can talk about that later
maybe but
but um but it's it's recognizable so
that that term
arose as as a term defining action
civilization and
i think that even though we live in a
post-christian
society today um it's still a
post-christian
christendom it's still a civilization
that is fundamentally shaped by
christianity
and so my project it's in four volumes
you mentioned the first two of those
um i'm working right now in the third
volume the age of utopia
that should be out by the end of the
year and then the net final volume will
be on the 20th century
it's uh provisionally entitled the age
of nihilism
um this is an effort to understand how
christendom
um first of all arose and then over the
course of time
was changed and was altered into what we
see today which in many ways is
post-christian
but it still has as i say by using that
term utopia
it still has a very strong um kind of
root in
uh or roots in uh the christendom of the
past
yeah so that's what i'm trying to do
yeah and i think that
it's very i was i was really excited to
read the book because
you know some people have seen that i
interviewed tom holland recently
and he has a similar position in terms
of his discovery that
to what extent christianity is at the
core
of our value system is at the core of
what we understand to be a person you
know so many things about
how we understand uh reality comes from
christianity and the fact that it has
been so poo-pooed in the past and it's
been kind of
uh cast to the side you know it gives us
an opportunity to now tell a better
story and what i love about your book
is that you know tom focuses mostly on
the west and he
himself kind of expressed how he's
frustrated that he couldn't include the
east but in your
series that's really the story you tell
you tell this this global story of
of christendom and not christendom in
the sense of just a kind of political
dominance of of christian of the
christian emperors or christian rulers
but rather
this capacity to enter into a hint of
the kingdom of god in the world
through the this profusion of
christian identity and christian
participation
in in the world and uh and so i
like i said i'm really i'm really
encouraging everybody definitely to read
the book because it gives you a
narrative of history that we haven't
had in the past and one of the things
you want to do and maybe you can expound
on that a little bit for us
is you want to reconnect the east and
west story you want to
show us how there is an inevitable
connection between
the east and the west in the way in
which even the middle ages developed
yeah you know there's two things you
mentioned there that i that i think are
really important um
jonathan one is uh christendom as i
define it is not
a political system uh it's not a a a
union of church and state or something
like that you know the loss of which is
you know lamented by reactionary or cons
conservative christians today it's it's
much more than that
the state inevitably becomes part of the
scope
of christian the christian
transformation of the cosmos
world but that's only part of it and so
i located the origin of this
civilization with a supporting culture
as i define it
that directs its members toward the
heavenly transformation of the world
that's my definition of
christendom um i located it at the very
beginning of church history at pentecost
actually
because i think it's it's right there in
the book of acts and in other
early christian documents which i cite
in volume one the age of paradise
and um and for three centuries it was
it was a viable
dynamic element it was a sub culture it
wasn't the dominant culture
uh it was a proto-civilization it wasn't
a full civilization yet
but it was there from the start
continuously acting
in this world
is exactly what is a um a traditional
christian cosmology or understanding of
the world
um because i i think that there's
something we're missing in our
in our contemporary modern debate about
christianity
and that is how very um cosmologically
affirmative it was and historically
in that first millennium that i talked
about in the first volume
and it embraced the world it tried to
transform the world
didn't reject it and run away from it it
really was interested in
engaging it and that's what we're
missing i think a lot of the time today
yeah and i think it's it's very
fascinating because
people portray christianity as this
denial of
of the world and you know it kind of
this weird nietzschean vision that
christianity is a is a
kind of hatred of the world and uh you
know the naysayers yeah
exactly but that like you said that is
not what we see
there is this notion of self-sacrifice
all of this is part of of understanding
that
the christian you know self-sacrificial
love is the
the zeitgeist of christianity but the
fruits of that
are these communities that are bound
together in love and that
you know kind of flow out into reality
you know you see how
literally the saints died in certain
places and then
geography started to transform around
these saints relics and how
the world itself you know uh pilgrimage
places became
new centers for for civilization
christianity reorganized even the space
of the roman empire
not just it obviously reorganized its
ethics and it's its way of being but it
actually reorganized even the geography
of the roman emperor i mean
constantinople is the ultimate example
of how christianity itself reorganized
the empire it was the city
it was the christian city yeah right
yeah i mean absolutely you know
jerusalem became uh the center of the
world you know
and understood in the christian sense
yeah and that's why the crusades were
always focused on it so
so much um no so we could talk about
government politics and
and how that's really not the center
it's an important it's part of
the christian traditional christian
vision of the cosmos but
or culture but it's not the main center
of it
it's like you say it's the world it's
this it's the world that's filled
with the presence of a living god it's a
world that has
been penetrated by the kingdom of heaven
which is drawn near to it
what i call paradise that experience of
paradise
but the other thing you mentioned and
certainly i want to give time to this
too if you're interested in talking
about it is
that point that that you uh you know you
noted that i'm trying to
link east and west here this is a
history of the west for sure
most of my work certainly in volumes
after volume one like the one that just
came out the age of the division it's
mostly
a narrative about the west so there's
plenty about byzantium and russia there
as well
um and we'll be going forward but um
you know it's really interesting if you
look at the history jonathan
for the first millennium you know we in
the west were so used to thinking the
west
dominates the west you know kind of
leads the way culturally speaking
everything kind of
comes from the west and and if you go
back in time
it's like an onion peeling an onion you
start to see that there's no west
um there is a west but it's not really
it's not the center
if you go back far enough into the first
millennium you find the center is the
east
yeah and one of my chapters in the book
um age of paradise is called
uh uh when the uh when the west was
still
eastern and uh i talked there about how
for two centuries the popes of rome
which we think
essentially you know the kind of
symbols of western civilization at that
time were all
recruits from the east from syria and
especially from
uh constantinople and eastern parts of
the
uh empire at that time um
famous uh important fathers of the
church theologians who contributed to
our
understanding of culture especially what
it means to be human
anthropology and what it means to
what the world is cosmology such as
maximus the confessor
they were eastern they came to the west
maximus helped
organize a council in rome itself
and uh and these are people that are
just forgotten you know
gregory the great the pope of rome i
have a son named after him actually
um he was just a fantastic example
uh having lived in constantinople for a
few years
he came back and became pope of rome and
he's recognized certainly
in the west by roman catholics for
instance um as
as the most important like person of his
generation and beyond
um but he had a very eastern
understanding of the cosmos
and the place of culture within the
cosmos but it's interesting to be
recovered i think
there's a polemic there's such a polemic
reason why we've come to learn history
this way
right there's a there's one of the one
of the
let's say one of the tools or one of the
weapons of the enlightenment has been to
paint this idea of the dark
age this idea of the middle ages as this
dark regressive you know
backwards age and usually what they mean
is basically england and northern france
like that's that that's kind of
like it's france and england basically
that they're talking about maybe germany
is the kind of and it's only for a few
centuries and
if you take into account constantinople
the very idea of the dark age completely
vanishes there is no dark age
it it it it's actually that you know
constantine sets his capital
in the east and then that capital
becomes
the cultural center for all of
christendom
and the influence of constantinople
reigns all and even
even at the conversion of charlemagne
you can actually see
how charlemagne takes on the tropes of
constantinople visually in terms of
artistic history you can notice how he
takes on the imagery that he gets from
constantinople
uh and so like constantinople had
running water and had you know
education and had all the things of a
civilization
and so i think that the reason one of
the reasons why we don't know about it
is
a polemical reason is that we don't want
we don't
that the secular modern secularist
doesn't like the idea that
the middle ages don't exist the way that
you portray them
yeah you know the term medieval is
interesting i'm actually writing about
that
in the age of utopia as i as we speak
the the whole concept of the middle ages
of course as you say is a polemical
concept
it's a it's a weapon of the
enlightenment the term wasn't actually
coined and and then became kind of
established in western culture only in
uh after about 1700 during the course of
the enlightenment
and it was really the product of the of
the so-called renaissance when
first petrarch uh father of renaissance
humanism
uh likened the whole history the
thousand years that preceded him
as a darkness a cultural darkness that
overcame the west from which he needed
to escape
and his escape was into the seculum into
the secular
non-uh religious non-christian
unchristian kind of realm of the uh
of the pre-christian uh culture of pagan
of of pagan greece and rome
and others after him uh coined you know
this idea of of light and darkness and
then this was
this became kind of consolidated by the
by enlightenment
it really dismisses a thousand years
of of western history yeah it it
that's effectively what it does and you
can it's funny because in a way if you
look at the context you can have some
sympathy for petrarch like because he's
coming out of the plague and so you can
understand that
here he is like no seeing these bodies
dead all these dead bodies and this
whole
breakdown of of culture that's happening
because of a disease
and then projecting that back onto
history for the for for a thousand years
you know and so i mean i can
i can kind of have some a little bit of
sympathy for petrarch but i don't
necessarily have sympathy for those who
weaponized his
his vision in uh in the enlightenment
and
you know how can you look at a gothic
even like even terms of the west like
how can you look at a gothic
cathedral and say dark ages
and i don't understand how that's
possible i mean there was a breakdown in
terms of
of these non-roman pagans who were who
are kind of taking over for a little
while but as soon as they become
as soon as they become christianized you
see the transformation
start to happen and that's one of the
interesting things that you explore i
think in your book is that
on the one hand you're not afraid to
show the dark side of some of the things
that
happen even in terms of constantine's
conversion or charlemagne and all of
these
figures that convert and you can see
that that there's still
some elements that they have to deal
with that have to be transformed but
nonetheless you can point to actual
fruits
of the changes which occurred in their
conversion
even if it was in total so yeah
constantine did kill his
his son and that's a horrible thing but
in
in that chain from a pagan world where
it was absolutely normal
to to do that kind of thing it or this
constant uh
destruction of the of the hairs and and
this you know these
horrible uh emperors that were doing
monstrous things
you can nonetheless see the difference
and you can see the transformation even
if it's not
it doesn't bring us into the holy of
holies let's say right away
and it won't yeah for sure it won't in
this world and and i try to emphasize
emphasize that you know the age of
paradise so-called is not
an age when everyone lived in paradise
and everything was you know just happy
and
and beautiful and holy and you know good
no there was darkness everywhere i mean
it was darkness everywhere and there
will be darkness as i understand it as
as someone who reads
the scriptures and thinks about the
christian revelation
seriously i think they're always going
to be that darkness that petrarch
spoke of that pentebre in latin um
you know but what's interesting there
jonathan is it wasn't just
as i understand is i as i do the
research and think about it you know
when petrarch
had this reaction um to
this kind of reaction to his culture it
wasn't i think driven just by the
the the plague the black death which he
did live through his act
one of his sons um was actually perished
as a young man from the plague
so he knew it quite well but i don't
think that's really the main thing i
think what's going on there
um and this is what i this is what i
bring out in the second volume the age
of division
is that once that that disconnection
between
west and east took place once the west
no longer was rooted in eastern
christendom there's a real there's a
real change a real shift
in in the culture and i do believe this
is extremely important for understanding
why we're dealing with
um kind of out of control abortion and
and why we're dealing with
political correctness and all the other
stuff that afflicts our modern culture
today
because that detachment from a
civilization
with a supporting culture in the east
that directed its members toward
heavenly transformation of the world
when that happened
a great pessimism began to seep into
western culture you can see this
in what i call the stavrocentrism or the
cross-centered culture
of penitential pessimism the rise
of of of of the doctrine of purgatory
for instance which i look at real
closely in
the second volume all of this of course
following the
the great schism i call it the great
division
between east and west and and you start
to see a culture
that's very pessimistic and i think you
know jonathan i think that's really what
was
driving petrarch's turn almost best
return because he was a smart
brilliant man and so enjoyable to read
his turn toward what what
is called the seculum the secularity the
secular world is a world that is
un spiritually untransfigured
untransformed
a world that exists only for its own
sake and that is the beginning
of it it's a it's a flight from
pessimism
um the the pessimism of the christian
culture of the west
having um become just detached from the
culture of the east for a few centuries
now
that's really the beginning of what
became the renaissance
and its humanism and the enlightenment
and the detergification of art
um when art no longer had a liturgical
role to play and it just became an end
in itself
um the renaissance being the the classic
example of that
yeah and i think there's also this you
hint at it a little bit also in the book
and i have like i said
i'm still in the on the first 100 pages
of the second volume
but you know the problem of the uh the
iconic classic controversy
it's something which people especially
as an artist i take that very seriously
but it's something which is ex it's very
important and
and people ignore how charlemagne
and the frankish court is meddled is
like
mixed in with the whole question of the
iconoclastic controversy
and the solution that the franks gave
and that the the west ultimately kind of
arrived to
was something which didn't totally
integrate theologically the image
which kind of said we have these images
but we don't see them as liturgical we
don't see them as
participating in this in the reverence
and the veneration and then
ultimately kind of moving up towards the
worship of god and
and i think that that's that's like a
little i don't know if you talk about
that but
i've always thought that that's a little
seed which was already planted in the
west and then
as the renaissance came and then the
reformation came
there were no arguments people didn't
have
uh they didn't have uh saint john of
damascene's incarnational argument
to be able to explain why we have this
stuff
in the church and so it kind of this
kind of fell flat by the time the
protestants arrived no one
i i think john calvin even in his when
he talks about
images he doesn't even address in john
damascene's argument he doesn't talk
about the incarnational argument at all
so that was all the way back during the
time of the iconoclastic controversy
where the excess of the east and the and
the kind of
and the west this strange mixture
created this problem which
which just continued on right
you know the the west never developed a
really clear
coherent understanding of the image you
know
in the east of course with iconoclasm
they were forced to and john of damascus
and
and theodore the study came forward and
and articulated as fathers of the church
articulated
what the image is you know and like you
said it's it's grounded in the
incarnation it's grounded in traditional
christianity's
understanding that the world is not
disconnected from
heaven from god from paradise but the
world is filled with
presence sacramentally especially and
liturgically
the presence of heaven and that's what
the image and the theology of the image
does in the in in the east and in the
west
uh charlemagne's court you know we're
talking charlemagne for your listeners
and viewers i mean it'd be like about
800 so this is still before the great
schism
but it's about 800 this is going on and
his frankish
theologians they didn't get that at all
they saw the image
as being pedagogical only as being
something that's useful for teaching and
that's that's
that's that's fine that's good that's
part of it but as the fathers of the
seventh ecumenical council
in the east had said it's it's good for
teaching but primarily
it bears witness to the fact that god
became human in the incarnation the
world the cosmos is not
on its own uh living out its life for
its own sake it is now joined to heaven
and to eternal eternity and that's that
really is the break
i think that's it and after that you
know you mentioned the renaissance
boy i mean you talk about what was going
on in the renaissance
and calvin's reaction to it you look at
what the renaissance did with art the
humanists i mean
our culture celebrates michelangelo and
raphael
and and titian and all these famous you
know leonardo and
but if you look at these from a from a
deep
historically deep point of view
it's it's an it's it's just a an
aberration it's it's
it's so weird to see what they were
doing with their art
yeah i agree i mean obviously i agree
that's why i'm an iconographer
and uh you know i had that this
interesting discussion recently with a
catholic uh
uh thomas you know about this problem of
nakedness in art and why
in the west they've kind of accepted
that and i really i see the
to me the the renaissance is a pagan
move it's a it's a move towards a
pagan thinking a pagan aesthetic and
pagan sensuality
and so like you said there's a sympathy
for
calvin or the reformers were reacting to
this
like you were wrecking through rubens in
a church with all this like naked
like orgiastic flesh in the altar and
you're like okay so this is it like this
is what we're gonna have in the church
now so there's a
there's a certain sympathy for for as as
you move into extremes sometimes you can
understand
the reaction to to something which is
already excessive and then it moves into
another excess and then
after that it's the history of the west
it's just from one excess to the other
from one extreme to the other all the
way into the you know into the utopian
age of our of the
of the modern world right now but i love
like to me i
i'm really happy that you say that
because i've been kind of secretly
secretly thinking that the iconoclastic
controversy and
this the relationship between
charlemagne and the conflict that
happened
and the wars of the iconoclasm that
happened at the time are
are one of the key key moments in the
definition of the west
and the the separation between the two
and how
the the problem of understanding the
incarnation and the transformational
aspect of reality appears very clearly
in that moment
where you know even today when i talk to
to
to catholics and protestants sometimes
when i talk about the transformational
aspect of what christ brought and how we
are called to be brought into god and to
participate in the life of god
you know like the people they they don't
feel good about that they feel uneasy
about it
but you see an example of that right
there in charlemagne's court at that
time
yeah and that's simply the doctrine of
the incarnation you know that's why
the orthodox east is very comfortable
using the word
theosis or deification when it talks
about its understanding of salvation
it's not just
you know release from condemnation
um uh escape from punishment uh it is
but it's much more much more than that
it's participation
in the life of god and and that's that's
really
central to it yeah there's a i keep
i hate keeping this harp on charlemagne
i mean because i'm french is one of the
reasons why i'm so interested in
charlemagne but
the fascination of that moment to me is
so important because
you see even that as charlemagne is
distancing himself from
the east and saying i'm the emperor and
he was named emperor after
irene's deceased husband like in the
order of
of of uh he wasn't like emperor of the
of the west he was like
emperor after the byzantine emperor and
so
as he's distancing himself he's taking
on all
the visuals of the of the east and so
you can the carolingian renaissance is
basically
a kind of westernizing of byzantine
uh imagery and you see it in the in the
in
the ivories and the imagery and the
mosaics all of this at akin like this
kind of golden
uh look that he's trying to imitate so
it's a weird it's an interesting like
i'm separating myself
but i'm also being completely influenced
by this this society
that's it it's it's very strange it's
almost you know
schizophrenic because there is this
total identification with the byzantine
example the emperors of
rome or the byzantine emperors and um
and
charlemagne now assumes that because
he's conquered so
much of the west and he wants to
integrate a big powerful imperial state
now
pope of rome has gotten fed up with the
east because of iconoclasm
and it's irene i mean i mean the empress
said i have sympathy for them as well
i wouldn't like what would you have done
if you were pope and then you know this
empress is is
killing you know her own children and
like okay what do we do here
declaring herself emperor and like okay
this is not going well
oh it's intolerable what was going on at
the byzantine court in the east was just
intolerable over and over again and
and it was heroic for the papacy to try
to find you know to stand up against
that
and and as i say the the papacy played a
very heroic role
in much of the first millennium and even
beyond
um trying to you know correct uh
mistakes that were being made by
political
authorities especially emperors you know
like that but
back to you know to charlemagne what's
interesting there
is that on the one hand he totally
identifies like you say he builds his
new temple
in akin famously built and modeled on on
byzantine architecture
he assumes this almost cesaro papa's
kind of
um he's he's almost like a priest he
couldn't you know he was really
interested in
theology he had theology read to him
charlie may be sitting at his
dinner table in his palace hall and he
would order his servants to read the
city of god by augustine
while he's munching on his dinner you
know i mean that's that's the mind that
charlemagne that charlemagne had but his
theologians these frankish theologians
were so i mean they're like the the
first um
cultural activists you might say they
were shocked troops
of a new western identity that is
distinctly and by definition
not eastern you see and that's the break
that's where it starts of course
nothing's
done in a single generation in history
but that's where it really starts you
start to see the formation of an
identity
we call the west distinct from the east
or
the greeks so so i think what what
happens after charlemagne is
you get this different culture which
defines itself against
the east not with but against the east
then the great schism comes a couple
centuries later 1054
is the excommunication then after that
all these
changes start to happen under the
influence of the papal reformation of
that time you get papal supremacy
you get um you get the um uh the
the crusades starting within about 50
years of the great schism
um beyond that you get doctrines like
purgatory
which projects um the experience of
paradise for someone
you know living in that culture
purgatory is this
tremendously you know um
intimidating uh process of punishment
after death post-mortem punishment
that that the effect its effect on the
culture
of the of the west is is profound uh
that culture becomes
inherently you know very deeply
penitential pessimistic
um the experience of paradise that i
tried to document in the first
millennium and
my first book gets put off until after
that purgatory
you know plays out uh thousands of years
whatever a year
isn't it beyond this world and and so
you you get all these you know the
the um the paintings of giotto as
beautiful as those are in the 14th
century
those paintings you know are intensely
um
they're designed to create an intense uh
reaction or response
of of sorrow and penitential
um uh uh kind of doubt
and and and and and introspection
um that itself contributes to a growing
pessimism
and and so this this tendency in in the
west
after charlemagne and the great schism
is more and more to
to lose that incarnational culture
that was so strong in the east and so
strong in the west too
during the first millennium but now
after the great schism
and that great division it becomes much
weaker
that's what happens with petrarch and
the uh and the renaissance so-called the
humanists come forward
and they say you know this is and
they're not they don't put it this way
petrarch almost puts it this way but
they don't quite put it this way but
what they do is they
seek they seek um they seek
human fulfillment no longer in a world
that's been transformed
by heaven they seek human fulfillment in
a
world for its own sake a secular
so-called secular world
and that's their contribution that's why
renaissance painting is
so naturalistic and so fleshy and
and so focused on the artist as genius
you know
michelangelo's signing you know the
story about his pieta that famous statue
of the virgin mary holding the dead
christ
that gets put in uh saint peter's he he
kind of he
he finishes the the uh the carving of it
and one of his most famous works
and it's put you know for everyone to
come look at and he stands back in the
shadows we're told by a contemporary
account
to see what the reaction is because
artists are very very competitive
then and for commissions and all that
and some
bumpkin comes in from the countryside
and says that's beautiful
who did that and some guy some bumpkin
standing next to him says
i think it was a guy named raphael i
don't know what he says exactly that's
not michelangelo
michelangelo recorded that he became
infuriated he went home that night
and came back to the church with the
hammer and chisel
and he chiseled right across the strap
of the virgin mary's uh chest
this is the work of michelangelo and
that's the
there have been autographs before that
but that's the origin of the artist's
art
autograph that's so necessary in modern
art you know the artist
is is is pushing the limits has radical
things to say
and to reveal or michelangelo's
decoration of the sistine chapel
you talk about like revolutions in
liturgical life
this is a chapel with an altar and over
the altar you see the sea of naked
bodies right it's it's incred it's the
last judgment too it's not even what you
would see
the incarnational icon in the east was
the the virgin mary of the sign
with christ you know being born into
this world of
from from a human mother now it's the
last judgment and all of its terror
um you know the the famous uh creation
of
of adam and the system example uh he
modeled his
image of of of god creating adam
uh he modeled him on zeus if you go back
and you'll get statues of zeus
this highway you know this like he's
been to you know gold's gym or something
that's really
you know oh chest and he just looks
with a white beard and all that stuff i
mean that's just it's beautiful and it's
in a in a worldly
sense but it no longer has any
liturgical or sacramental significance
at all
yeah there's so many things wrong with
that painting i can't even start
like why the naked like all the naked
babies and why is there like a naked
teenager
next to him and it's just very
disturbing michelangelo's paintings are
very
are very disturbing uh look at rafael
think about you know the
famous sistine madonna um you know
that's the one of his many madonnas
by the way rafael is writing about this
in my new volume the age of
utopia it's accounted by by a
contemporary
his name was vasari about the history of
the lives of the painters you probably
know about it
he said that rafael was like a total
womanizer yeah
and he would you know he would he would
seduce his uh his female models that
were sitting
as models for him and modeling is a
totally new thing too
um and when he was pain they would they
were they were
modeling the madonnas for him but in
assisting madonna
he's got those two little what are they
angel thingies i call them
yeah they they changed they had these
figures in roman art which were called
puti where like
these little domestic gods you know like
these little babies with
with wings and and then they
they somehow changed the cherubs into
these poochies and so
the cherubs which are these like flaming
you know
flaming glories of god with like multi
multi
eyes and wings became these cute little
uh
naked babies with wings you want to poke
them in the belly like the pillsbury
doughboy
and they become totally insignificant
and powerless and that
i think jonathan is the sign of the
shift in culture now
for a secular transformation of the
world from a heavenly one
the heavenly powers you know the
archangels angels seraphim cherubim
i mean stand about the throne of god you
know we can quote the divine liturgy
um these no longer are relevant so they
become these two little bored looking
cutesy little um angel thingies at the
bottom the painting
and that really becomes the image in
baroque
painting as you know better than i yeah
of what an angel looks like like it's
just a cute little powerless
unintimidating baby
because there are no demons to worry
about because man is autonomous you know
that's pico
uh de la mirando's uh argument um
in the dignity of mandarin that during
the renaissance that man is autonomous
he's in control of his own life now and
and
you just get this demonization this
diminishing
of the heavenly presence in this world
and angels are now represented even as
christ how do you pray to christ when
he's
a naked little baby you know i mean you
know with his
forgive me but his genitalia exposed
that's not a liturgical image anymore
yeah
it's interesting though is that
something that i've been thinking about
in terms of art
there's something like for example
michelangelo's work it
never landed right it never landed
it never created a tradition it never
created so nobody copied his images
nobody copied
those paintings and made them into other
whereas i think that there's a there's
still an implicit thing
in the catholic tradition there's still
the possibility
of so there are still images which
appear later which become
almost iconographic you know in their
use let's say so if you have someone who
has little saints cards with a prayer
behind it
you know there's something about that
which even though
they don't have the theology to explain
it there's an intuition
that people have about their connection
to
the saint and the way that say that
these little saint cards that that are
cheap and you can buy at a little gift
shop
the way that they're framed even though
they're still western and they still
have a kind of photo photo type realism
to them
they've been sobered up they've been
brought into a kind of more
frontal pose all of these elements of
iconography
nonetheless kind of persist in this folk
in in in a kind of into intuitive folk
world that continues to exist
even though in the big churches in the
high churches there's all these
diagonals and all this madness and all
this
these floating investments and all of
this kind of craziness
you know for the for the humble pilgrim
and the the little
person who has a the card of a saint in
their
in their house it'll still look
something like an icon there'll be a
little bit of a tinge of
of a remembrance of that of that world
because it is more connected to how we
actually engage people we the type of
we don't you don't meet naked people and
you you can't
you can't pray i mean i don't know like
have this like kind of sensual naked
person in front of you and
you're supposed to you can't look at
them in the eye and then
invoke them or you know ask for their
prayers whereas these little saint cards
where you just see the figure looking at
you
with a bit of a glow in the back it's
kind of tacky but nonetheless it has
that
it has a little bit of the iconic memory
let's say
it does you're right about that and i
think that's just instinctive it's maybe
intuitive
um there's also of course this revival
of um eastern iconography you know you
see in a lot of
western churches these days yeah but i
think that's
that's what people are seeking um i
think that that's
what human beings were paid for was a
connection with heaven
and um and and that's the way we we make
it you know we don't make it
by looking at a fleshy image even if
it's in a jerk even if it's over an
altar
it doesn't do anything it keeps us
locked into this world into the secular
it keeps us in the secular and man was
made for more than the secular
and and so that's why people are trying
i think especially today
to find a way out of this i think
there's a it's really a cultural dead
end
artistic dead end and i mean look at the
20th century you know because of the
disintegration of the human figure you
know that just
you know i think humanism as it was
expressed by michelangelo like you said
he never
he never really created a tradition that
followed him
i think humanism just spent itself by
the 20th century
you know it was seen more and more by
first nietzsche but then
artists of the dada movement and the the
the dolly and the the surrealists and
others
picasso for sure it was seen as a
counterfeit as
something that was just you know didn't
have substance and it's interesting
because even if you look at the history
the there's a little microcosm which
happens in the renaissance which people
don't like to talk about so much because
by the end of the renaissance there was
a movement called mannerism and you see
it even in
in michelangelo's late work where it's
as if
this kind of glorious realism and this
kind of glorious sensuality of the
beginning of the renaissance
quickly turned into this strange
exaggeration
the stretching of figures the the excess
in color
and and so you have this weird
manneristic painting which happens at
the end of the renaissance
which is only broken by the council of
trent and this kind of
this kind of glorious baroque but you
almost see a microcosm of what's going
to happen in the whole story
right there in the renaissance by the
end of it you have a disintegration of
form
and then if you if you take a bigger
loop all the way into modernism you have
the same move which moves all the way
down into
because as you kind of explore the
sensual aspect of
of something as you fall into the
passions those passions
have no limit right and they start to
turn into weird things right
you know the weird you know and that's
you can see that in the madness of
pornography today where it's like it
goes into all these weird little
uh like fetishisms and stuff and so it
was already there like right in the
renaissance at the end of it
and then the whole modernism like you
said you can see like by the time you
get to france's bacon
you're like you know that you know what
a portrait by francis bacon
was promised to you in michelangelo
already at the beginning
post-modernism yeah francis francis
bacon is a good good example of
where this all goes yeah exactly exactly
um
and so one of the things that friends
bacon know he he passed away i don't
know
a while ago i think so yeah a very dark
figure even
himself like he he himself manifests a
lot of the
of the darkness of of what the
nihilistic 20th century
is you know in his in his story as well
in many that's what
that's what the artist um of the post
renaissance post
chiseling autograph is all about is
self-stimulation um you know driven to
create um not to reflect heaven or
anything else but to be the center of
creation and
radical breaking from everything that
preceded it
and and and sadly that is i think just
creates a
maniacal kind of personality the modern
artist
yeah exactly but you look at you look at
traditional iconography
as you well know jonathan i mean the
the standard the way of life for an
artist
a byzantium was to fast to fast you know
to pray to receive the sacraments
on a regular basis and then to hand on
tradition um through the image that has
been already preceded you and you don't
radically alter that image
yeah and there's been there's been an
effort to
now we have some iconograph some
iconographical saints you know saint
andre
uh has been recognized as a saint you
and you can get an icon of of
andre rublev and so there is this this
and
his you know he was a monk his whole
life was a was
it was a transfigured life and so it
showed in his in his painting
um so i one of the things that i really
like about the book
is how you you also you it's really
what i like is that it although you have
a perspective you
you're careful not to fall into polemics
as well where you show the promise for
example like we talked about charlemagne
you show the promise of charlemagne like
how this could have gone like it could
have been it could there
there are some positive aspects which
could have gone well and then showing
how no
this is how how things happened you know
you do the same with constantine
a real like there's a certain amount of
realism in the way you approach it you
show
the positive aspects of the papacy the
negative aspects also
even of how the moments when
constantinople was in heresy and was
completely off the off the chart and so
there there isn't it isn't just like a
it isn't just a it's not a polemical
work in that sense it really is trying
to
tell the bigger story right so that
people can have a east-west
vision of this christian culture which
if you just show one side of it
you you you lose out on so much of of
how
the world ended up uh and so i don't
know have you seen
someone else do something similar to
what you're doing because i haven't
really
seen that on the horizon i haven't no
i haven't john and that's that's what
motivates me i i guess you know is
you know i mean i love the west i i mean
well we're westerners
yeah yeah i mean i do and and i mean i'm
you know we were talking before we
started uh
we're just chatting a little bit you
mentioned something about i think some
positive things about the west science
and such
i i i would i would really be at a loss
i can't even imagine you know
what i would be i mean i can't but
without classical music and i can't
access classical music without modern
technology you know
i mean i've listened to i've listened to
tchaikovsky's
sixth symphony like probably well of
course that was his last let's do
something early like his
whatever his uh violin concerto i've
listened to tchaikovsky's violin
concerto
a hundred times or a thousand times more
than tchaikovsky ever listened to it i
mean that's one of the incredible things
about
modern technology is you know we can
access
things like that i can just play that
you know as i'm driving or working or
whatever
and there's so much that's good yeah but
um
the back to your question what's
happened is
that there really is it's it's maybe
polemical it's maybe
just about an unconscious bias but there
is this sense
that there is no ease someone knows
something about there's a russia
and it's always associated with a guy
named putin you know and that's kind of
it
uh maybe there's some ballet maybe you
know there's tolstoy that's kind of the
end of it
and um there's a you know star trek
didn't he
use a character called check off or
something like that it's like i mean
it's so
minimalized and it nothing's known about
it and
and that's what i was trying to do a lot
of people
who are today
um of which francis bacon that we just
spoke of
might be a good example of uh that is to
say
the problem of art um and morality and
stuff like that
a lot of people who are concerned with
the the the issues of today
trace those back if they trace them at
all a lot of people just talk about them
i think that's why trump was such a big
deal because people don't really want to
think about history they
or the past or origins of anything you
just want to solve the problem
i in an immediate sense but if people
think historically about
where this came from you know i think
it'd be interesting to do kind of a
survey but i think
i think probably the majority of people
are going to say it's the sexual
revolution
yes 60s you know that stuff um those who
are maybe a little bit more
like you know formed educationally
might say oh no it's more like the
enlightenment didn't that to us
and then others might go further back
especially if they're roman
um they might go back to the protestant
reformation there's a brilliant book out
there
by um by a guy named brad gregory he
teaches at notre dame
called the unintended reformation yeah
how a
religious revolution i forget how the
subtitle but it's essentially how the
confirmation
i gotta control and produce the
pluralistic world
culture yeah and it's really interesting
and some would say that's really when it
happened but
but what i'm trying to do is say you
know what if you go back even beyond
that you find that it's really the great
division
that you know can be marked at 1054
although that's not really
everything yeah and charlemagne and and
that's really when we see
the change that began to accumulate and
uh and and and and meet to where we are
today and no one
again to answer your question my
knowledge in the west i don't know what
they're doing in russia or
or greece i mean jana ross is a famous
greek
orthodox way scholar and he's written
stuff like
um about kind of with historical kind of
insights into things um some others have
as well
but no there's almost i mean there's
nothing that i know of that's out there
right now tom holland is someone that
you mentioned i loved his book dominion
i
i really loved some of his other books
as well um but you know he's it's just
not on his radar
and having grown up in orange county you
know i mean
at you know in the 70s i was never told
anything about the east i mean
i wasn't told that there even was an
orthodox church there was roman catholic
and
protestant churches and those are the
two christian
traditions that are you know behind the
the civilization we live in and and um
i don't think anyone's doing that right
now no i mean i think
i think like i've seen some people i was
thinking while you were talking about if
i i've seen some people do that but
sometimes
it's done in a way that's so polemical
that it's almost it just turns you off
right
so if i think that it's important to be
able to see
for example in the the conversion of the
north northern people
and to understand that there were some
positive elements in the franxx as well
there was this
this desire to be christian and you can
see it in the art you can see it in
in the architecture that there is a
positive element to it but that
nonetheless there's a seed which is
planted
and you can kind of see the seed being
planted and it starts to grow and grow
and grow and at some point the fruits of
that
uh start to appear and it doesn't mean
that within that there wasn't also some
there weren't saints there were saints
there there were people who who were in
embodying this paradisial uh reality
even though
even though kind of let's say the
current was going against them
but that it that we can nonetheless
notice
that the change was planted quite early
in the in the history of the church and
just kind of
took form as as time went on and so it's
hard to say because i'm a french person
and so
like i i don't like going against let's
say my own
my own tradition and that's why i also
want to be able to see the the
also the energy of the north let's say
is something which i think is
is important because it also happened in
russia too it didn't just happen in the
in the west it happened
both in the east and in the west and so
there are positive elements of that
energy that came down from the north and
created some of the great kingdoms you
know the norman kingdom uh
of sicily and all these kind of uh these
magical places which have a lot of
strength to them
but nonetheless that seed was planted
and you can't avoid it
yeah no you're right and and there was a
lot you know that's really admirable
about frankish
civilization um and it's spread in
anglo-saxon and celtic you know i end
the age of paradise on on the an island
of the furthest
the westernmost island of christendom
which is a scale of michael you know off
the coast of ireland
with the celtic monks they're about the
year 1000 praying
and um and the celts you know what had
this tremendous tremendously
cosmologically affirmative
piety that that really is so consistent
with everything
that we see in the first millennium and
and and beyond that the the papacy
played heroic
a heroic role and really was trying to
you know edify and
increase the the quality of western
civilization for centuries
when the protestants came along they
were doing a lot and have done a lot
for for modern civilization that's for
sure
yeah and so father john i want i want to
thank you for your time and i really
want to encourage everybody to go
and get his book his books now and
also check out the podcast which is is a
kind of longer
uh spoken version of some of the things
that are in the book and also his blog
on his website i'll put all those links
in the description so you can
uh follow follow father john in his
musings and in his thoughts about
history so far john thank you for your
time and hopefully
you know once i finish your next book
and maybe the other one we can have
another conversation
about how all this unfolds you bet
jonathan
yeah thanks for having me it's nice
talking to you all right